チェッカーゴールデンウィークなんだよなぁ
ゴールデンウィークなぁてかけたいんですけど
によっと twitter ツイッターゴールデンウィークずっと仕事を慰めて
頑張ってる
米ちゃおう料理代スティ
[音楽]
ただコーパス竜田揚げ棒先生ですよろしくお願いします今日調理するのはこちらうまい
棒等でございますまるだ
そういうことだ消費したいんですよ全然やらないんでなんかゴールデンウィーク中僕に
もし合ったりしたらうまい棒あげるんでぜひ声をかけてくださいという意味で早速
うまい子調理していきましょうよメガネ潰して食ったりすると何か今モンハンになり雪
みたいなのがあります
僕の中で人気で今日はちょっとこのふざけんじゃねぇってくらいあるうまい棒を消費
するために甘いのでちょっといろいろ料理をつけてみると思いますならさっきにメモを
とったんですよそれでも計算してないと何を混ぜれば本物になるかというの何か僕の頭
の中で想像したんでそれは実際に今回やってみようと思いますこれはみたら
食費が浮きますよ奥さんとヤりやってくださーーーん
w
用意するのはコンピューターず3つと多分お湯でいけるんちゃいますか
応用音止めますパワーを準備しまーすそれぞれうまい棒もこの場にしてローンでもう
これだって見るからに金ボタンやんこれも別にさあやる前からちょっと分かってねって
言うとがある訳も重いんでもいいから書いておける早速お湯を入れていきましょうこれ
で完成する説がある気がするんですけど
うーんパットにこんぽたじぇねこれやも本人と言っても過言ではないでしょ
ちょっと混ぜます
範囲と良いで完成しましたでも見た感じ結構いい線いってるのではないかなと思って
おりますが
いただきます
まずなんでだなんでだあはから多分今パターン少ないんだ
ここだぜ1本で穴噂だから物の水で薄めると甘くなくなるのは当たり前のかもっとコン
ポタージュ入れてきます
わーっ
[音楽]
あっ方やまあ本当に家族だけは第二章4話できました
配分見せたコンポだぞみたいになっている混ぜたらなんかそれっぽくなってきましたよ
これいただきます
おっ
持った
ああああああああ
あーなんか失敗したコンポタージュの味ですね
大次はたこ焼き味でございますこれがシンプルに高い家の味がするんでなんか水と混ぜ
て高慢女たらた早くになるんじゃないかという安易な発想でございますやってみ
ましょうオスは子どもにします
今の彼らはバラバラなんですけどもこれをちょっと整備を利用せひとかたまりにしてみ
ます
はいできる青背景青きれいな丸と言えないんですけども
5を1カウンターバルにはなっていると思いますなんかもうほんとてバイクじゃなくて
一緒にも錯覚したらこいつの価値力だったらお前は
わけです
これはシンプルにご飯にかければソース活動ができるんじゃないかという考えですねお
肉禁止してるんで声をかせ紛らわして食うしかで楽しみですパロディあ
[音楽]
あまあまあまあまあや結局ずあのソースカツ丼の味がすればいいんでそれだけ教えて僕
はていただきますいただきます
[音楽]
ん
あああああ
音声アジアソースかけだけノラ子ですあず盗んでは大丈夫ですかカツ丼のなんか先に
勝つだけ食べ終わっちゃってその後般若の中活動の汁だけちょっとかかっちゃった
ところのあんまり汁がかかってない方の中ご飯のところを送って食べた感じですそう
だけでやけどおいしい装置かけたらまずで美味しいと思います
まずでソースカツ丼の数だけ食べにく
ちゃって余っちゃった白ご飯あのソースがあんまりかかってないほうがご飯の端っこの
方の味がしますね完全にソースカツ丼なかったかサメに食べちゃって残ったて白ご飯の
ソースかかってないものの白いご飯サゲツの方がこれ完全に
もちろん野菜さズって言えば今なんか丸めたらポテトサラダみたいになるんじゃねえか
なって感じでこの豚肉だいた後に大湯をかけて丸めます
[音楽]
ん
いきましたすいません見るに耐えませんいただきます
問題は味なのですよ
失礼します
[音楽]
ん
me
ゼロです
って
チキンカレー味をご飯にかけるとファ0になってください
うーんお肉系捨てるとう金を貯めれないだよ
どこのカレー屋さんに入ってる最中に口の変更隠蔽してやってカレーが食べれない人
動くことじゃないって一回も彼来てるんです
チキンカレーを今食べたら嬉しいなぐらいの感じで頑張ってみようと思います
匂いだけはいつもに彼ですねワンチャンあるじゃねーかな見た目だけちょっとカレーっ
ぽくなります結構期待してますから
できますん
こレーダーうっ
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
me
これを普通に潰してご飯にかけたら納得外ごはんになるんじゃねってなお悩みが
正しければこれ頃にかけるだけの旅納豆ご飯になると思います
[音楽]
うん納豆ですいい匂いですね
かけて来ないん
日々良いですね過ぎ次へ納豆ご飯 new になっちゃった船と匂いは嫌いになって味
は好きなんでさぁにより伴い味までもが納得はになっていると嬉しい
いただきます
[音楽]
ん
ぽっぷっ突破ばっばっバーン
てい
rar
納豆なんですねブー
みんな俺ナビに従うわからんこの2つを混ぜることによってテリア9チーズバーガーが
できる
ほんと本もうまい棒にも見せればきっといい感じ夏になるんじゃないかなと思います
います
55これが期待できる
止め中森場みたいになってますが蓋をします
うまい棒とパンだけで体でぐチーズバーガーを作ることが可能だったのでしょうか
できないん
おっ
うーん
わからんん
me
ええええええ
えっあっ